l'assassinât de l'ambassadeur américain
à beyrouth prudence à washington arrivé
à paris du président assad la france et
la syrie s'explique sur le liban valéry
giscard d'estaing sur antenne 2 le
pouvoir c'est moi lui dr n'est qu'un
parti émeutes raciales en afrique du sud
déjà 23 morts et 250 blessés le début
des épreuves du bac le début de la vie
d'adulte
c'est le dossier de journal bonsoir un
crime odieux c'est ainsi que le
président de l'ol paie monsieur yasser
arafat et le leader de la gauche
libanaise
monsieur joumblatt ont réagi à l'annoncé
de l'assassinât l'ambassadeur américain
à beyrouth et de son conseiller
économique
c'est pour eux une provocation qui
encore une fois risquent de faire
reculer un éventuel accord de paix jean
lefebvre dans un instant nous rendra
compte de l'état d'esprit qui règne à
washington mais à beyrouth ce matin les
services de sécurité de la résistance
palestinienne aurait arrêté cinq
personnes
ils seraient les auteurs du meurtre et
appartiendraient à l'organisation
révolutionnaire socialiste arabe très
rapidement retrouver les auteurs de ce
double attentat seront livrés aux forces
de sécurité arabe les casques verts qui
devrait en principe arriver demain à
beyrouth palestiniens progressiste et
phalangistes aucun des adversaires sur
le terrain l'a voulu endosser la
responsabilité de ces meurtres
chacune des organisations allant même
jusqu'à promettre de dévoiler le plus
vite possible les dessous de cette
affaire ce qui semble accréditer de plus
en plus l'hypothèse d'une provocation à
laquelle pas plus beyrouth que
washington n'ont voulu répondre
l'amérique est indigné mais l'amérique
ne bougera pas la presse américaine
traduit aujourd'hui l'émotion générale
en gros titre vous les voyez en termes
sévères geste absurde meurtre un
qualifia actes de provocation mais écrit
le new york times répondre à une
provocation ne pourrait que détruire ce
que nous avons accompli ne faut donc pas
satan un débarquement de marines
américains sur les plages de beyrouth
comme en 58 tout au plus l'amérique fera
t-elle dégager ses ressortissants
menacés
un porte-avions croise au large de
beyrouth on le confirme à washington les
commandos sont prêts mais on n'ira pas
plus loin
d'abord parce qu'on est en année
d'élections on est à quatre mois du vote
maintenant et le président ford
pas plus que son concurrent probable
jimmy carter n'a envie de mettre le
doigt dans un tel engrenage
et puis et puis une intervention contre
qui contre quoi l'amérique ressent
plutôt une profonde amertume depuis
plusieurs années on voit le moyen-orient
comme un nouveau vietnam
alors on s'efforce de raccommoder les
morceaux d'étouffer les flammèches
kissinger croyait bien y être arrivé en
faisant cohabiter les israéliens et les
égyptiens au moins au sinaï
la guerre civile au liban remet tout en
question et maintenant on ne voit plus
comment éteindre l'incendié si tout le
monde s'en mêle
y compris bien sûr les russes d'où la
précipitation du président ford a
affirmé que la recherche de la paix par
les voies diplomatiques continuera un
nouvel ambassadeur américain va être
dépêché immédiatement sur place
l'amérique ne bougera pas mais
l'amérique n'abandonne pas non plus ce
secteur stratégique du monde
alors que le liban vient d'être le
théâtre de ce nouvel acte de violence
que les combats entre syriens et
palestiniens se poursuivre malgré un
léger relâchement du blocus de beyrouth
le chef de l'état syrien a été accueilli
cet après midi à orry par monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing
c'est la première fois que le président
assad se rend en visite officielle en
occident on l'attendait à paris au mois
de mars
mais en raison de la situation au liban
le voyage avait été reporté est il plus
opportun il y a trois mois il aurait été
axée essentiellement sur les relations
économiques entre les deux pays
aujourd'hui la visite du président
syrien nous amène à poser un certain
nombre de questions
c'est la première fois que monsieur
giscard d'estaing venu à orly accueillir
son hôte à sa descente d'avion rencontre
cet homme de 46 ans austère peut-être
jusqu'en paraître timmy rarement la
venue d'un chef d'état à lui de ces
conditions le président syrien qui après
paris devait faire escale en yougoslavie
puis en roumanie à renoncer à ce projet
estimant sans doute qui ne pourrait
s'absenter aussi longtemps de son pays
en ce moment de particulière tensions
sur un portrait général et douze mille
hommes de l'armée syrienne sont
incapables de dominer la situation au
liban
sur un plan cul particulier la syrie
n'est même pas en mesure d'assurer la
sécurité des diplomates en poste à
bairon alors pourquoi ce voyage à paris
d'abord pour hafez el-assad
si d'une occasion inespérée de se faire
connaître en dehors du monde arabe la
france est un excellent tremplin
international et assad avec habileté et
il en a paraît-il de contrebalancer sa
perte de prestige dans le monde arabe
par une plus grande notoriété en
occident c'est pour lui en ce moment
précis un enjeu de taille
enfin la france a proposé ses services à
plusieurs reprises le président hafez
al-assad peut raisonnablement au cours
de sa visite
faire un certain nombre de demandes s'il
y avait un consensus interarabes et
qu'on demande à la france d'intervenir
est ce que la france enverrait des
troupes
la france s'est déclarée disponible lé
rêve elle est et reste disponible dans
les conditions précises qui ont été
mentionnés notamment par mois le 6 mai
ceci dit ne nous hypnotise ont pas sur
cette affaire du dispositif de
consolidation de cessez-le-feu bien
qu'il a été mentionné et précisé dans
les mêmes termes qui a fait gaffe
qu'elle que la france par les pays
arabes pour le moment il faut surtout
que le processus politique se poursuivre
et à cet égard un autre aspect des
propositions françaises n'a pas été
mentionné je tiens à le rappeler c'est
que nous sommes aussi prêts à faciliter
l'organisation de tables rondes pour
mendier si on nous demande encore une
fois si les libanais lui demande si tous
les libanais nul demain nous serons
prêts à faire quelque chose à cet égard
l'essentiel c'est qu'une table ronde
réunissant tous les belligérants
s'organise très vite la diplomatie
française s'y emploie et s'il y avait
accord sur ce point ce serait peut-être
le résultat le plus positif que l'on
pourrait espérer du sommet franco syrien
le dialogue entre les deux chefs d'état
s'est amorcée cet après midi à l'hôtel
marigny c'était leur premier tête à tête
ils en auront deux autres pour clarifier
leurs intentions particulièrement en ce
qui concerne le libre
ce n'était pas des confidences que
jacques chancel à recueillir soir sur
antenne 2 de la bouche de monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing le président de
la république a bien sûr répondu aux
questions d'actualité brûlante
non il n'y aura pas de remaniement
juillet non il n'y aura pas d'élections
anticipées oui ils pensent que le projet
des plus values se révolter mais
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing en
outre affirmé qu'il n'envisage pas de
réformes constitutionnelles avant 1980
pour monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
la fonction de président de la
république est unique et c'est à lui dr
aux gaullistes qui l'a rappelé les
principes de la vème république
cette fonction présidentialiste est
absolument incompatible avec telle ou
telle proposition telle ou telle
agitation qui s'observe l'heure actuelle
et qui voudrait par exemple que la date
de nomination d'un premier ministre ou
la composition d'un gouvernement fut
décidée à partir d'une certaine
agitation parlementaire où la suite de
telle ou telle indication de partie je
vous rappelle qu'il n'en est pas
question que je maintiendrai dans les
institutions de 1958 qui font les grands
acquis la france actuelle la
responsabilité bien entendu
présidentialiste nous voulions être fixé
nous le sommes
non pas tellement sur le fait de savoir
s'il y aura ou non un remaniement dans
un mois même pas sur ce que pense le
président de son premier ministre
c'est important à savoir bien sûr mais
ce n'est pas l'essentiel
l'intérêt majeur de cet entretien entre
valéry giscard d'estaing et jacques
chancel
c'est la définition par le président lui
même de la fonction présidentielle
c'est l'affirmation de la préséance de
cette fonction sur les autres instances
ainsi les questions que nous posions ici
même et que les français se poser depuis
que des députés de la majorité
rué dans les brancards allant jusqu'à
défier plus ou moins ouvertement
l'elysée ces questions ont trouvé une
réponse nette et ferme le président élu
du peuple prend le pas sur le
représentant du peuple et a fortiori sur
les partis politiques
le président par sa fonction est unique
tels sont les termes mêmes employés par
valéry giscard d'estaing reste les
différents cas d'école que l'on peut
toujours imaginer changement de
jory t à la suite d'élections
rétrécissement de la marge de manoeuvre
du gouvernement type de situation que la
simple réaffirmation de la préséance du
président ne suffirait peut-être pas à
dénouer visiblement valéry giscard
d'estaing ne pensais pas à cela
hier soir les problèmes du jour lui
suffisent pour le moment ce qui compte
c'est que la majorité actuelle se le
tienne pour dit nous approuvons ce qu'a
dit le président de la république
notamment lorsqu'il se pose en gardien
vigilant des institutions institutions
auxquelles nous une r nous sommes
particulièrement attachés comme vous le
savez elle aura peut-être avis plus de
crogny tout rentrait dans l'ordre mais
c'est beaucoup moins simple que ça la
démocratie c'est un c'est le régime des
crises mais des crises heureusement
résolu
la démocratie c'est la possibilité pour
chacun de s'exprimer
alors je crois que nous aurons franchi
ce problème des plus values nous aurons
encore d'autres difficultés mais et
d'autres problèmes
mais l'essentiel est d'être d'accord sur
l'essentiel
or nous luder nous sommes d'accord sur
l'essentiel on sein de la majorité
auprès du premier ministre et du
président de la république
depuis 16 ans jamais la situation
n'avait été aussi grave en afrique du
sud et la politique de l'apartheid est
sans doute une des raisons fondamentales
du déroulement des événements
23 morts et plus de 200 blessées hier
dans la banlieue de johannesburg
et ce matin folie ces émeutiers
s'affrontaient encore tout a commencé
dans le quartier noir de soweto la
police a chargé une manifestation 10 et
africains voilà tout a commencé ici nous
sommes dans les faubourgs de
johannesbourg dans une immense cité
dortoir une sorte de bidonville réserver
ou le puissant mignard de la capitale
l'émeute a été déclenchée par un
incident qui a opposé les écoliers noir
aux forces de l'ordre
aussitôt la police a tiré et un garçon
de 13 ans s'est écroulé touché mortels
tout de suite c'est le feu aux poudres
les habitants noirs investissent les
bâtiments publics
le poing tendu symbole du pouvoir noir
en afrique les manifestants commencent à
lapider les voitures conduites par des
bleus
bien sûr l'armée intervient massivement
car il faut à tout prix rétablir l'ordre
dans ces quartiers en effet jamais
depuis 16 ans la violence n'avait
atteint un tel degré l'armée ne fait pas
de détail pas de demi mesure et le tir
23 morts et 250 blessés
c'était hier soir les émeutes était
encore localisée dans la banlieue
lyonnaise
mais ce matin la violence a gagné le
coeur même de la capitale est cette fois
des blancs se sont opposés à d'autres
blancs en effet ces étudiants vont
manifester en faveur des noirs contre
qui la police est intervenue dans les
rues de johannesbourg des habitants
blancs favorables à la politique de
séparation raciale c'est à dire
l'apartheid vont essayer d'empêcher la
manifestation
là aussi les incidents sont très bons
après l'angola l'ardesi ces émeutes et
cette violence en afrique du sud
marqueront sans doute un tournant
important dans l'histoire du pays et de
l'afrique
à 24 heures de la fin de la campagne
électorale quatrième volet de la série
consacrée aux élections italienne le
parti communiste le vatican il y a
quelques semaines a jeté dans la
bataille tout le poids que représente
l'église en italie en menaçant
d'excommunier ceux qui soutiennent et
communistes aujourd'hui même le pape
vient d'excommunier 1 ab parce qu'il n'a
pas caché son intention de voter
communiste c'est que demain
d'après les sondages le parti de
monsieur enrico berlinguer pèsera sans
doute aussi lourd que la démocratie
chrétienne la crise italienne ne se
résoudra pas sans lui on a tout dit sur
le parti comme le site et même qu'il
pourrait prendre le pouvoir après les
élections du 20 juin
mais là il ya sûrement un malentendu
d'abord il faudrait que le parti
communiste devient le premier parti
d'italie
or ce n'est pas évident les sondages
n'ont jamais accordé plus de 33% des
voix aux communistes
ensuite il faudrait que le parti des
laïcs opèrent les libraires et
l'intention et la volonté de prendre le
pouvoir ce n'est pas le cas on ne
gouverne pas avec 51% des voix a dit un
jour berling verts les communistes
veulent participer au pouvoir mais avec
les socialistes et surtout avec les
démocrates chrétiens
enrico berlinguer à proposer de créer un
gouvernement d'union nationale après les
élections les industriels et les
banquiers qu'ils prospèrent si les
richesses sont mieux réparties l'église
et les catholiques
laissez venir à moi les vrais chrétiens
répond berling were l'alliance
atlantique
c'est mieux que le pacte de varsovie
l'union soviétique le communisme italien
ne se fait ni à moscou ni à prague mais
à rendre les communistes ont voulu
rassurer tout le monde et ils ont réussi
dans une large mesure même si 22
millions d'italiens continue de refuser
l'envoi aux parties de berling web
maintenant que va-t-il se passer le 20
juin et bien exactement ce que berling
ware a essayé d'éviter ce sera un
référendum pour ou contre la
participation les cobistes au pouvoir il
est vrai que les communistes italiens
font moins peur mais sans doute parce
qu'ils sont dans l'opposition
leur donner le pouvoir c'est autre chose
elric oberling were le sait bien
ce n'est pas un référendum qui le
portera au pouvoir
l'église n'est pas un parti politique
c'est la réponse de l'épiscopat au
discours de georges marchais il ya huit
jours à lyon il s'était adressé aux
chrétiens de france en leur proposant la
main tendue les évêques français
aujourd'hui ils lui ont rétorqué les
chrétiens ne sont pas une force
d'appoint
les catholiques feront toujours leurs
choix politiques en cohérence avec leur
foi
pour la petite histoire le nom de
georges marchais n'est cité nulle part
dans le communiqué de l'épiscopat
georges marchais encore lui sera
candidat au conseil régional de l'île de
france qui doit s'installer le 1er
juillet prochain le secrétaire général
du parti communiste français est
candidat tête de liste dans le collège
des députés son élection ne fait aucun
doute car il s'agit d'un scrutin à la
proportionnelle qui garantit semble-t-il
à la gauche très élu au conseil régional
accident à boulogne billancourt une grue
tombe sur un immeuble il y a deux morts
et huit blessés
conséquence semble-t-il d'une fausse
manoeuvre d'une énorme grue qu'il
travaillait sur un chantier
cette grue a écrasé l'un des bâtiments
voisins deux hommes sont tués le grutier
est atteint gravement et dégâts
spectaculaires car le contre poids qui
pèse 10 tonnes a complètement transpercé
la toiture de l'immeuble
enfin en football saint-etienne champion
de france après sa victoire hier soir 4
but à 0 contre avignon une victoire avec
bonus les verts sont certains maintenant
de garder leur couronne
avant même le dernier match de samedi
contre reims ils ne peuvent plus être
rejoints par nice saint-etienne champion
de france est aussi la grande aventure
de la coupe d'europe qui recommence
l'année prochaine monsieur jacques
chirac a passé sa journée avec les
dirigeants agricoles
il les a rassurés la conférence annuelle
qui fait le point de l'évolution des
revenus agricoles a été cette année
presque essentiellement consacré aux
conséquences de la sécheresse
le premier ministre a décidé de créer
immédiatement deux commissions la
première chargée d'examiner tous les
problèmes pratiques tels que
l'approvisionnement en fourrage est en
nous et la seconde se penchera sur
chacun des cas particuliers pour aider
les entreprises en difficulté de
trésorerie pendant cette période de
sécheresse aider les éleveurs à garder
leurs troupeaux en mobilisant tous les
efforts pour la recherche de fourrage
soutenir les cours à la production sur
le marché de la viande engager la lutte
contre les spéculations éventuels tels
sont donc les mesures immédiates
arrêtées par le gouvernement des mesures
de survie pour les financer un premier
crédit d'environ 50 millions est d'ores
et déjà débloqué j'ai également confirmé
naturellement que les engagements qui
avaient été pris par le président de la
république et par le gouvernement
concernant le maintien du niveau du
revenu agricole en 1976 par rapport à 75
serait tenu que dès le mois de septembre
à la fin du mois de septembre c'est à
dire après des récoltes
nous ferions comme convenu
le bilan en matière de revenus pour
l'agriculture et que nous dégageons
union les moyens nécessaires pour donner
les aides directes compensatoires aux
insuffisances de revenus qui pourraient
être enregistrées notamment due à
l'achat à la sécheresse
et il a une nature elle il est normal
que la solidarité nationale s'exerce au
profit des agriculteurs cette année est
touché par la crise comme elle s'est
exercé l'année dernière et il ya deux
ans et comme elle continue d'ailleurs à
s'exercer au profit des travailleurs du
secteur industriel commercial ou
artisanal touché par le biais du chômage
par la crise économique que nous avons
connu l'ensemble des décisions
techniques annoncées par le gouvernement
semble bien accueillie par les
responsables professionnels se sont dit
on à la fédération des syndicats
d'exploitants agricoles des mesures
importantes
tout comme la promesse de la solidarité
nationale à l'égard des producteurs
sinistrés pour les agriculteurs c'est un
petit peu le seul espoir en ce paquet
qui le reste c'est de dire après des
années de difficultés après des années
d'efforts de voir que ce travail est
détruit pratiquement on ne vous dit pas
aux résultats et il faut que l'ensemble
de la société comme elle l'a fait
d'ailleurs l'année dernière lorsqu'il ya
eu les gros problèmes d'emploi et bien
elles viennent les agriculteurs mais je
peux vous assurer que pour eux c'est une
mince consolation parce qu'il
préférerait beaucoup voir leurs revenus
s'améliorer uniquement à partir de du
produit de leur travail
ils sont 240 huile en gros a tenté
depuis ce matin de décrocher cette peau
d'âne qu'on appelle le bac toute l'année
en s'en moquant un peu et qu'on nomme le
baccalauréat ensuite lorsqu'on l'a
obtenu 240 milles filles et garçons plus
les pères les mères les grands parents
les frères les soeurs qui bénéficieront
si l'on peut dire de l'ambiance en fait
c'est une foule de français qui chaque
année sont concernés sur lesquels au
fond rejaillit la gloire de la mention
même passable ou l'amertume de l'échec
qui toujours et de justesse ils sont aux
concernés nous sommes concernés par ce
que le bape quoi qu'on dise reste l'une
des institutions les plus solides de la
société parce qu'il est l'un des repères
les plus fermes de la valeur
intellectuelle et de l'énergie au
travail des jeunes
le mouv atelier n'est plus employé sauf
dans les vieilles poésie mais son sens
pèse encore lourd au point que chacune
des réformes imaginer entreprises par
les ministres précédents ont soulevé
finalement plus de passion dans
l'opinion profonde que ces plus values
dont on nous parle tant
le bac dont on dit que monsieur habib
prépare prudemment une nouvelle mouture
le bac est en réalité l'une de ces
choses solides dont la date chaque année
rappelle que l'été arrive et qu'il est
temps que ces jeunes gens qui chaque
jour font le monde commence par
démontrer comment il pense et jusqu'où
il juge le bac c'est finalement comme
ils disent le bizutage de leur vie
d'adulte
je pense que nous allons revoir bientôt
le dossier qui suivait ce point de vue
des diplômes du bac de 17 cents et
quelques est-ce que c'était rare à
l'époque sont des diplômes qui sont
extrêmement rares à l'époque les
universités délivrer au plus chaque
année dans l'ensemble même pas un
millier diplôme c'est un diplôme qui
étaient rarissimes peut-on dire et laver
une grande valeur sociale se disent ils
il à quelqu'un me chalié il avait une
grande valeur mais vous savez que sous
l'ancien régime les fonctions n'étaient
pas déçus mais forcément
d'après les pitres que posséder les les
candidats au contraire elle été plaidée
fonction s'acheter sous l'ancien régime
elle retire de l' empire sous napoléon
est ce qu'un bachelier c'était quelqu'un
qui était sûr d'arriver quelques
semaines d'ateliers avait très sûrement
une place dans l'administration ou dans
l'armée
parce que les grands corps de
recrutement et l armée l'opposé chaussée
tout ce qui pouvait servir à la
politique napoléonienne qui fait quand
même une politique d'expansion et
d'expansion
vous dites est surtout et puis quand la
république est venu quand les
républiques se sont succédé plus en plus
de gens alors là il ya eu de plus en
plus de gens et à partir de 1850
vraiment débâcle des bacheliers avaient
très très fortement augmenté ce mois-là
on en comptait quand même chaque année
plusieurs milliers mais un des grand
père qui possédait le baccalauréat vers
d'après ses mémoires on sait que il
avait un grade qui lui amenait une
considération extraordinaire dans son
entourage
ce sérieux cette considération qui
entoure le bac va durer très longtemps
voici une génération encore le diplôme
de la république c'était quelque chose
que c'était un problème qui préoccupait
les familles longtemps à l'avancé et qui
préoccupait beaucoup les candidats aussi
il était évidemment content de savoir
que c'était le dernier
le dernier rush avant les vacances mais
d'autre part c'était un obstacle à
franchir qui était en assez
impressionnant on avait l'impression que
ce serait très important la réussite ou
non ah oui c'est elle c'est elle apporte
indispensable qu'il fallait franchir
tout au moins dans certains milieux
faute de quoi rond
on se discréditait et sa province ont
vaqué souvent des drames familiaux
l'examen scolaire c'était difficile ça
vous a semblé difficile
ah oui c'était difficile il fallait
quand même savoir beaucoup de choses et
et il fallait normalement avoir au moins
un bon vernis sur tous les sujets on
n'imaginait pas enfin ou très peu ou
rarement de faire l'impasse comme je
crois saas répond ça fait plus répandue
depuis
est ce que le titulaire du brevet
supérieur en 1939 à votre époque était
quelqu'un de considérer de plus
considérer qu'un bachelier aujourd'hui
croyez vous très certainement
d'abord ils viennent chose ils étaient
beaucoup moins nombreux il y avait
beaucoup moins de jeunes qui poursuivait
des études et qui atteignait soit le
baccalauréat de l'époque soit le brevet
supérieur qui se passait et les enfants
de milieux pauvres avait dû subir des
quantités de barrières avant d'arriver
là il y avait quand même une certaine
sélection qui avaient été faites parmi
eux sélections qui avait sans doute bien
des défauts qui a parfois aussi quelques
heures juste après la guerre le
diplomate toujours la même allure mais
en 1950 événement capital
les études secondaires deviennent
gratuites à cette époque bac c'était
déjà une première étape de la
démocratisation de l'enseignement parce
que les études qui était payante au
lycée jusqu'à cette époque était devenue
gratuite
il y avait encore une sélection c'est la
sélection du concours d'entrée en
sixième alors c'était encore un bac
réserve et non pas à la masse des
enfants mais à une certaine élite bisous
alors finalement la démocratisation de
l'enseigné mort du bac
salah d'évaluer sa la diva lever la
mesure où il ne permet plus d'entrer
dans différentes carrières et un de nick
maintenant on demande des diplômes
supérieurs et qu'il n'a peut-être pas et
qu'il a perdu certainement c'est ce
cachet qu'il avait à l'époque où nous
étions peu de bacheliers ensuite très
vite la généralisation des études
secondaires va permettre un accès massif
aux précieux petit certificat quand il
ya trop de billets de banque la monnaie
dévaluée tout le monde sait cela
alors quand il ya trop de diplômes l'un
passion du [ __ ] soit existe tous les
quelques bacheliers rares et respecter
l'autre fois sont devenus des millions
et les possibilités de promotion sociale
ont bien changé avant le bac pouvait
nous offrir beaucoup plus de porte
maintenant basse assez restreint s'ils
veulent avoir le bac mais aussi d'entrer
dans d'autres écoles et demi après niort
si vous êtes bacheliers vous en serez
fiers
dans mon combat
c'est vrai que c'est pas rentrer dans
une affaire d'autres études c'est tout
n'est pas à trouver du travail
non on ne peut rien faire avec
aujourd'hui pour réussir il faut le bac
sans doute mais il faut autre chose de
plus comme on dit dans les épreuves
écrites
la condition est toujours nécessaire
mais elle n'est plus suffisante
un tiercé aujourd'hui à vincennes il
vous fallait jouer le 6 le 17 et le 13
alors si vous avez gagné dans l'ordre il
rapportera 3 1100 francs pour safran et
dans un ordre différent 426 francs 50
toujours pour 5 francs un coup d'oeil
sur la météo il a fait aujourd'hui
encore beaucoup de soleil à temps très
sec et chaud 17° aux armes et rentrent à
perpignan et puis pour demain eh bien
rien ne changera quelques nuages près de
la manche et la mer du nord des orages
du roussillon aux halles c'est avec
toute la rédaction d'antenne 2 que je
vous souhaite de passer une soirée comme
vous les aimez bonsoir si vous n'avez pu
assister en entier au journal voici les
principaux titres de l'actualité que
nous venons de développer
après l'assassinât de son ambassadeur à
beyrouth washington choisi la prudence
sommet franco syrien thèmes essentiels
des entretiens la paix au liban l'app
téléscopie de valéry giscard d'estaing
sur antenne 2 lui dr approuve les
émeutes continuent en afrique du sud il
y a déjà 23 morts et 250 blessés
demain le dossier de notre journal
vitaly était l'un gouvernable à 23h40 la
dernière édition avec gérard holtz